Oh
[Music]
cousins are built to last right 100
years 500 years a thousand years so why
build a castle that only exists for
three months and has to be rebuilt every
single year when it mounts well what if
that was the point
what if you are building it not to the
finished product but just as you like
building stuff
we're just creating forefront creating
something that's going to melt and
because you want to make sign that looks
like it belongs in a fairy tale I'm
sleeping beauty it's nice to meet you I
was just blown when I saw her it blown
away even if it can't last forever but
then the best things in life ever do so
in what faraway land of ice and snow
might you find this unique us tell me
what state oh this is the aptly named
White Mountains National Forest
now there's no doubt that this is one of
the most beautiful parts of the country
but people who don't like the cold tend
to stay away because temperatures here
have been known to fall as low as minus
100 degrees Fahrenheit with wind chill
yes minus 100 degrees we have two trees
we have a lot of friends and we have the
ice castles for the last four winters
this hidden corner of New England has
been home to the ice castle a gargantuan
structure made up of over 25 million
pounds of ice thousands of visitors come
to explore the turrets tunnels slides
and sculptures that seemed to have
sprung out of the ground like magic they
have really fun slides later than them
[Music]
and a fire for you bang princess I was
scared she's gonna blow the whole thing
now
then we [ __ ] called the fire
department and then something about
would happen then maybe she'll get
arrested Arabella we are best friends or
worst enemies depending on the day
Arabelle completely looks up to Liliana
I think she wants to be like Lily one
day how did you feel when you first saw
the ice castle I felt amazing I felt
like how did they built this it could
feel magic and it might have that magic
I don't know the ice castle is in fact
filled with magic but it's the kind of
magic that results from a group of
crafts people working in sub-freezing
temperatures for a curative 8,000 hours
we actually harvest our own icicles here
and then we take them and stick them
where we want the ice to grow and then
we turn on the sprinkler system and
overnight it'll grow together and once
it goes together it's strong enough to
get up on top I mean keep building from
there and there's another group of
people who helped shape the castle
without even knowing it the visitors
themselves I like for people to touch it
and get in it and see
interacting with the ice they're
essentially helping me carve because the
heat from people's mittens and bottom
will continue to carve the castle and
smooth it out I'm gonna try to knock off
this part yeah it is fun
it's all here no no we start building in
December usually it's close enough I
think you have to be 18 but you to
supply a woman I really like telling
children how it's made
I'm like this is the next generation
whoever this I like to work with happy
accidents and ice is great because you
don't have a lot of control it's all up
to the weather and it changes all the
time New Hampshire it's a tough place to
live because you have to be able to
handle the winters I think everyone's a
little stir-crazy and you just don't
know what to do when you're trapped in
your house all the time and especially
if you have kids feel like art could
help to make connections and work
through things how do you spell sadness
or is a great way to work through
problems and emotions and putting
emotions into something is that you yeah
I feel for my children because for most
of their life it was almost you know
picture-perfect
and then it went from perfect to
crumbling really fast
well my mom and my dad got in a divorce
sometimes stuff is just for the best and
sometimes that's just gonna happen
Christmas wasn't like all the
Christmases before so we went to the ice
castles and I think it was just the
pick-me-up we all find it needed there's
a day away from reality and it was this
magical you know maybe it's not a bad
thing that they're experiencing
heartbreak so early on because they're
learning that there is life after
heartbreak you can go through something
and you can be in a lot of pain and you
can get through it and you can come on
stronger
and both side I would give her a hug and
say it was trying to think those are
good times you have other good times
that you will have
[Music]
all good things come to an end maybe
that's what helps us realize that they
are good things and besides who knows
something even better might be around
the corner I'm happy to see it mill it
needs to be renewed it needs to melt
sometimes though Mother Nature needs a
little bit of help
[Music]
the ice castle is so big the even when
temperatures get above freezing it has
to be knocked down because it takes too
long to mount I definitely embraced
change dive into a season and then as
soon as you're sick of that season that
seasons gone and there's a new season
when spring comes I start to garden as
soon as the drips of the ice castle
start happening I was like okay let's
have some springtime I want to see
plants first out of the ground and I
want to tackle them
[Music]
are you excited to get about next year
yes I'm so excited because maybe there
will be another firebrand princess and
the slides hopefully will still be there
and maybe there will be a little change
[Music]
you